-My next guest is a fantastic
actor who you know from
films like "Crazy Rich Asians"
and "The Gentlemen."
His latest movie, "Monsoon,"
is available in virtual cinemas
and on demand on your favorite
streaming platform.
Here is Henry Golding, everyone.
-Hey!
-Oh, come on!
It is so great to see you.
-What's up, Jimmy?
-Ah! Thank you so much for
coming on the show.
You look great, buddy.
Before we start the interview,
I just want to say,
I wish you were in person so I
can say congratulations,
because you and your wife, Liv,
are expecting a baby!
-We are! Our first. Man!
I made the most out
of quarantine, you know?
-Yes!
-We got there.
-That's great!
-It's literally the only time
that we've spent longer than
two or three months together
without traveling.
So, I think a lot of people
were like,
"This is the time you've got to
concentrate on family.
This is the time where
you reconnect."
And we just made the most of it.
We're so excited.
-We need good news these days.
This is such good news.
Honestly, you're gonna be
the best dad.
Congrats on that.
-Oh, I appreciate it.
-Before we talk about your
movie, "Monsoon,"
I want to ask you about another
movie you're starring in,
"Snake Eyes."
It comes out next year.
-Mm-hmm.
-Snake Eyes -- this is from --
Anyone who knows "G.I. Joe."
I was into "G.I. Joe"
growing up.
Probably a little bit too late.
I think my parents
had to be like,
"Okay, you're too old for this."
But I was watching every day
after school and into it,
into the cartoons.
I had all the action figures.
-Damn!
-And now -- Wait.
So, is this like
an origin story?
-So, this is -- Yeah, it's
Snake Eyes' "G.I. Joe" origins.
We start all the way from
the beginning
to get to the core of
who this guy is.
It's super-exciting.
-This is a giant, giant, giant
action movie.
-Oh, yeah.
-I mean, was it "Gentlemen"
that got you into the --
everyone was like,
"Oh, he can do action great"?
-They definitely went out on
a whim for me.
Like, they had no idea
I could achieve any of this.
-Did you know that
you could achieve it?
-Luckily, like,
my movement's pretty good.
I've been boxing for a little
while and a bit of Muay Thai.
But it put me through my paces.
We had like four hours of
choreography every single day.
We had two hours of script work,
then like an hour of P.T.
For literally 2 1/2 months,
I could not sit on the toilet
and I could not -- Well, and if
I made my way to the toilet,
I couldn't get up
from the toilet.
Literally,
my legs were in ruins.
-Really?
-But it was worth it,
because I became a weapon.
I'm not going to lie.
-Yeah.
You actually brought us footage
of you rehearsing
some of your fight scenes
and you cleared it
with Paramount,
so thank you for doing this.
-I know.
This is a world exclusive.
Nobody has seen anything,
apart from a photo from behind.
-Here's Henry Golding training
for "Snake Eyes."
Look at this.
-Hey!
-Oh!
Yeah! Come on, dude!
-Yeah!
-Oh, my gosh! Oh!
And face! Yes!
Oh, my gosh!
-You've got to do the look-away.
You have to do the look-away.
If you look at the fallen bodies
on the floor, it's not cool.
You've just got to, like...
-Of course.
You walk away from the explosion
like it didn't happen.
-Exactly!
-It's right behind you.
It's over.
That was -- I mean, Look at the
work that just went into that.
That's one scene in the movie.
-I know.
A little different from
Nick young of
"Crazy Rich Asians."
So I'm super-excited
for everybody to see this.
Sadly, you know,
with everything going on,
we had to move it from
this October to next October,
but it's going to be great.
-Next October, "Snake Eyes" will
be in theaters October 2021.
Thanks for brings that footage.
I'm so psyched about that.
Let's talk about "Monsoon."
It is out now.
-Hey!
Can you tell everyone
what it's about?
-Yeah. It's about a young man
who's Vietnamese
but grew up in the U.K.,
much kind of like my story
of being Malaysian and
growing up in the U.K.
-Yeah.
-He finally finds
his way back to Vietnam.
And a lot of time when you go
back to your motherland,
you kind of feel
this sense of like,
"Oh, I'm going to feel
a connection.
I'm going to be home."
But a lot of the time
and more often than not,
there's a sense of alienation.
You don't speak the language.
You don't understand
the culture.
So what would or should
feel like coming home
feels very, very weird.
So, it's a young man
delving into his past,
his history, and trying to find
kind of his true identity.
-Wow! I know that before movies,
didn't you host a travel show?
-That's right, yeah.
-I remember you saying that.
Did you ever try to connect to
your roots or find out,
you know, where exactly --
-You know what
the greatest thing was?
When I was doing all the
journalism for the travel shows,
I actually brought my camera
and I sat my parents down,
and, through the filter of
a camera, they just open up,
because, like,
talking to face-to-face is
so difficult sometimes.
So when you kind of make it
into an interview,
something else in their brain
kind of triggers,
and they're like,
"Oh, I better tell the truth" or
"I better tell, like,
the entire story,
not the convenient truth."
-Wow!
-So, I did that and I have this,
like, beautiful footage
of my parents letting me know --
like, telling me
how they met,
what their lives were before.
And it's so difficult to
get that out of them sometimes,
you know?
-You know who's really going to
benefit from this?
Is baby. It's the best.
-Yes.
-That's so true.
-Oh, buddy, that's so cool.
-I'm going to store
this interview.
-Yeah! This is the opener.
-Play it in the crib.
-Yeah.
Just add the name in later.
Like..."Enjoy the clip of your
dad talking to his parents."
You can add that in post.
You put that in post.
I want to show everyone a clip
of Henry Golding in "Monsoon."
Take a look at this.
-I mean, there are some parts
that remind me of
the Vietnam I grew up in,
mainly the poorer parts,
like that street behind
the hospital.
-When we first met, you said it
was your first time here.
-Did I?
-Yeah. You did.
-I lied.
Sorry.
-Why?
-Keep it simple.
-You just can't get enough
of me, can you?
I have that effect.
[ Both laugh ]
-Henry Golding, everybody.
"Monsoon" is available in
virtual cinemas and on demand
on your favorite
streaming platform.